alex hayes apophis qui a été retrouvé ce
matin à 8h30 au premier étage suicide ou
meurtre
les avis divergent mais une chose est
sûre le grands concertistes alexeï
issakov qui n'assurera pas sa
représentation de ce soir
il leur faut donc occupé neuf suspects
sont identifiés et à ce moment là il a
appris que de la personne qui devait lui
tourner les pages
vous pouvez pas venir michael ii nièvre
était la doublure du pianiste il assuré
les représentations avant et après les
spectacles et les séances de dédicaces
des liens très professionnelle alors au
début ça se passait très bien entre nous
et puis petit à petit on peut dire que
ça s'est un petit peu dégradé la
situation s'est tendue entre nous une
enquête de deux heures pour identifier
les 50 indice et des interrogatoires
comme celui d'olivier berthe un ancien
pianiste est aujourd'hui critique
musical moi ma certitude c'est que c'est
un suicide parce que je sais j'ai écrit
dans un article qu'il était malade à
l'organisation de cette murder party la
compagnie tisseur de songer
l'association tout ce qu il y plusieurs
semaines de création pour aboutir à ce
cluedo grandeur nature évidemment il ya
eu un meurtre et les participants
doivent trouver qui est le coupable ou
la coupable
mais le fond de l'histoire c'est que
nous on écrit toute une histoire on a
travaillé des personnages on écrit un
fil narratif un axe est donc en fait on
découvre toute une histoire et on est
vraiment entre le jeu entre cluedo
grandeur nature et le spectacle 200
participants ont relevé le défi et
découvert la vérité pour tv 78 le
mystère reste entier